if your life could have dlc what kind of
deal see what you have would you have
like post game content something like
Ian out of this world or extra friends
like in Mass Effect what am I romancing
options for the extra friends loyalty
missions that's too much ever how about
a new outfit DLC that's got clothes
shopping that's exactly what I want
clothes shopping the LC I could have
swaggering pimp coat anyway sometimes I
think that games companies don't take
DLC seriously enough I mean that George
Washington Assassin's Creed thing extra
gun packs extra Golden Gun packs it is
all rubbish I mean come on I know what
the people want and by the people i mean
me this is what I want far cry 3 blood
dragon dlc was awesome there were
dragons with laser eyes Michael pine and
more neon than a 90 Soho sex dungeon the
rook islands would have been perfect for
knockoff Jurassic Park DLC but that ship
has sailed so what about far cry 4 I
mean I definitely be game for chucking
some c4 onto a Velociraptor making a
purse out of a gallon limas hide before
riding a Stegosaurus triumphantly into
battle enkindle this far from being just
a big stupid jellyfish blasto was the
galaxy's first Hannah Spector and his
series of high grossing movies lover in
every port and a gun in every tentacle
made him the James Bond of the Mass
Effect universe you interrupt the
filming of blast 07 blasto goes to war
and mass effect 3 Citadel but a prophet
dlc where shepard and blasto team up to
take on sovereigns half-brother sluggard
would be amazing imagine a buddy cop
movie in space by away you can have this
one for free okay the last of us left
behind dlc was pretty much perfect but
there was one story in the game that i
would have loved to have seen explored
in full in the sewers chapter of the
game you uncover notes written by a man
named ish who founds a safe haven for a
small community in the sewers it's a
wonderful piece of storytelling and it
left just enough questions unanswered
but I want to know more
out asian is fishing boat dammit let's
face it I just want more stories in this
world and of course to step on his skull
but hasn't the last of us been out for
ages now Shh that hasn't stopped saints
or for releasing a standalone expansion
like two and a half years down the line
we already know that GTA 5 is getting
story DLC what about high so be
ridiculous we know it's going to feature
all three main characters but the where
and how are yet to be determined what
would be great would be DLC like red
deads undead nightmare completely
separate to the main story but wacky and
full-bodied enough to stand on its own
two legs maybe something to do with the
aliens and Mount chiliad or just heists
I mean heists would be good never
happening but they promised people
promised a lot of things like the time
you promised to feed my fish when I went
on holiday game a whole apple and I
taught him how to swim upside down yeah
thanks for that anyway if there's some
DLC that you'd like to see just saying
that because it rhymes let us know in
the comments section below bro we'll see
you next time friends just doesn't rhyme